I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello. Hi there.
You look so cute. I think you look cute. Well, it's on brand for today's episode. Because today it's Meet Cutes and Office Romances. But first, we have some fun shares for our top of show. Angela, do you want to go first? Because your share required some heavy lifting. It did require some heavy lifting.
Shout out to Josh and Sam. Josh brought these in the house. We got this huge box delivery. And you guys, it is our Webby Awards. Yeah. For our whole team. Our whole team, Ainsley, Sam, Cassie, me and you, and I'm really proud of it. It is the 2025 People's Voice Award winner for podcast, shows and comedy.
Office Ladies won. Woohoo! So I think we should share that we have Cassie to thank for this award in a big way because the way this works with the Webby Awards is you get to like submit an episode. Yes, for consideration of being nominated. And the episode that we submitted was our Star Wars holiday special breakdown, which was Cassie's idea. Cassie, I would have never watched that, and I'm a Star Wars fan, had you not suggested it. You're welcome. Thank you.
It really is the gift that keeps on giving. I might have to watch it every Christmas now. I hear you. I agree. And then Ainsley, I think we owe you a debt for outlining the Star Wars episode. I'd say it was my pleasure, but, you know, it was. It was a pleasure. It was very fun working on the episode with all of you. But while you're here, I do have a question for you. Of all the crazy things we've asked you to outline for us over these many years, what has been the craziest
for you? Was it the Star Wars or was it something else? I would say the first seven minutes of just wookie speak has to take the game. Okay. And you know, know what I loved about your outline for it is when I could see your personality come through, like you would put in parentheses, they're still dancing. Yeah. For some reason, this is happening. Yes, exactly. It's very fun. So that's the episode that got us the nomination. And then, of course, all of you all voted. And that's how we got our award. And thank you so much. Thank you so much. And thank you to everyone who messaged us. I voted. I voted. Every time I saw that. It made my heart happy. Well, thank you for bringing those in today, Ang. I can't wait to put mine
on my shelf in my office. I love this award. Me too. And thank you, Sam, for, I don't know how you, like, it was like a game of jinga, how you, like, stacked all the boxes and carried them up. Yep, this is what I've been training for. There it is. There it is. Human jingo. I have some office real estate news. Oh, yes. Share. Michael Scott's condo is up for sale, everyone. In fact, there's a good chance that by the time you hear this podcast, it will have sold because the listing does say buyer pending. But let me tell you about it.
It is 7303 Bonnie Place and Receita, California, and it's currently priced at $710,000. It features three bedrooms, three bathrooms, with 1,458 square feet of living space plus a back patio two car garage and a gated entryway into the development, which I think this is a very good feature that they should really underline and put in bold in the listing because now everyone knows where this is. Right. And this way maybe people aren't just parked right in front of your house getting a picture with Michael's condo. Yeah, I mean, I remember when we shot there, we had to go through this like gated entry. You know, I used to live by the Brady Bunch house. Oh, did people come by all the time? Literally like those star van tours would come by. And people would unload from the bus and take pictures in front of it. And I know that this happens at Jim and Pam's house. Oh, and someone lives there. Yeah. People go take a picture in front of it. But for this condo, the listing does say this, quote, this home is a great starter home or a downsized home as it can be easily managed and maintained. This,
properties claim to fame, it was the site for the whole episode dinner party of the show The Office. Season 4, episode 13. I mean, who could ever forget that one? Well, you know, I follow Zillow Gone Wild. I love this Instagram account. And they post kind of like real estate properties that have a little bit of a, huh? Like sometimes you look at them, you're like, what's happening here? It's a really fun follow. And they posted photos of the condo. And the caption just simply said, this home seems like a nice place to have a dinner party. And I was just scrolling through, like, quickly, and I looked at it. And I commented, wow, I thought that looked familiar. And they were like, oh, my gosh, they reposted that. Because I didn't know right away.
You know, I didn't read the caption right away. Well, they post photos of what it looks like today. And it was crazy to look at them. There's no tiny flat screen TV above the fireplace, though. just a really nice piece of art in a frame. Is there a neon beer sign? No. There's like a sort of, I don't know what you would call it, like an iron work piece of art there. Very classy. Sure.
There are several candles. Oh, Jan. Jan would be so happy. Yeah, there's one in the center of the coffee table and then there's a bunch in the dining room. I mean, this is all I could think of. When I was looking at these pictures, I can't imagine what it would be like to actually tour the place. I was also like looking at the bedrooms. I'm like, oh, no bench at the end of the bend.
No, no. So on the actual Zillow site, like not Zillow gone wild. Right, right. They also put this in the listing. They said this property has several, quote, famous neighbors inside the complex, including Johnny Depp and M. Knight Sharmelon. Because these are, remember, like Michael thinks these guys might live there? Yeah.
I mean, they don't. But that's so fun. And like a clever little take on it for the website. They were having a lot of fun with it. Okay. One last thing before we go to break, we have some exciting Office Ladies Network news. Mm-hmm. So for a while now, we have wanted to add another show to our network.
That's right. We started the Office Ladies Network with The Lazy Genius. But just a few months later, I got my breast cancer diagnosis and I went into treatment. So we kind of had to put a pause on growing our network for a beat. But now that the bulk of my treatment is over, I've got my stamina back, we were able to get back to our dream of growing our network. And we have loved having the lazy genius on our network. We love Kendra. We love the community that listens to her podcast. And we were trying to find the next good fit for our office ladies listeners. Yeah, we were really looking for a great podcast that was also going to inspire that great community.
Well, we are thrilled to share that the next podcast we are adding to our network is a fantastic rewatch podcast called How We Made Your Mother. It is hosted by Josh Radner, who played Ted Mosby on the Emmy-nominated CBS sitcom How I Met Your Mother and the series co-creator Craig Thomas. If you're a fan of how I met your mother or if you're just a fan of hearing like the inner workings of how a TV show is made, then this is the podcast for you. Craig and Josh, I think maybe because one is an actor and one was a co-creator, you're getting both sides of the story in each episode. Yeah, you get very two distinct perspectives, which I loved. And they also have a fun rapport and fantastic interviews. I'm really loving their podcasts, and I can't wait for you all to listen.
So far, they have broken down every episode in season one. And like you said, Angela, they've had some great interviews. I absolutely love their interview with Kobe Smolders. Now they are starting season two. Yeah, and we're going to do a collab with them coming up. You know, sort of how we did the one with the PodMeets World folks. We're going to have them on to discuss an episode of the office. And then we're going to go on their podcast to discuss an episode of how I met your mother.
So please check it out. Season two starts Monday, October 20th. But if you want to get caught up, you can start listening now. You can find it wherever you get your podcasts. And we've also added a new team member to office ladies, everyone. Colin Anderson is with us now as our new head of network development. Yes, you might remember Colin from our Friday chit-chat. We discussed his kidney stone.
And you know, we met Colin years ago at Earwolf and we're so excited to be working with him again. And hopefully, because of Colin, you won't have to wait as long for our next new Office Ladies Network show. All right. Well, let's take a break because I'm ready for some romance and meet cutes. Well, listen, let's jump into the topic at hand, Meet Cutes and Office Romances. There are so many romances on the office. I mean, there's lots of coupledom, lady, and we sort of thought we had to dedicate a whole episode to them. Yeah, we asked Ainsley to do a little deep dive on office romances, but then I did a little research myself as well. Angela, do you know which office character had the most romances on the show?
Sam, Cassie, I open it up to you as well. I mean, I'm going to guess Angela Martin. I'm going to guess Angela Martin, too. Okay. Actually, Cassie? No, I'm going to change it. Sam's changing. To Michael.
Oh, okay. Cassie, where do you want to be in this? Yeah, I think I'm leaning towards Michael as well. The answer is Michael. Yeah. He had both of the most. major romances and what I would categorize as flings or short-term romances, can you name his major romances? His major romances would be Pam's mom. That's the first one that comes to
my. Yeah. No, I mean, Holly's not the love of his life. No, no, no, no. I'm leading with like all the randos. Okay. Leading with randos. Leading with randos. Also, obviously, Jan. What's her name from the hotel, concierge? Marie. Yes. The real estate agent, played by his real wife, Carol. Who is the bar owner? Yes.
Donna, date mic. I mean, obviously, Holly. Who else? Yeah, you've named the big ones. But then there are all the people he tried to date unsuccessfully. That's a whole list in and of itself. I mean, would that include Pam? That is okay.
That came up in my research because he does throw a couple of like half passes at Pam, doesn't he? Like at Diwali? Yes, 100%. Yeah. And he makes comments to her like, in another life, if things were different, maybe you and I. And she's like, in no life is there a you and I. All right. Who else?
Okay. Pam's landlord. Yes, Pam's landlord. Oh, right. So cringy. Yes. The Benny Hana waitresses. That was a crash and burn.
The girl from Blood Drive. Oh. Oh, that's... Oh, I loved that scene. I know. And then also chair model. Chair model broke his heart. That was a whole episode.
I love chair model. That makes me want to go back and rewatch that. I know. So Michael has. the most romances. And then it's like a big tie for who's next. Everybody in this list had like three major romances. Okay. I have a little list for you, lady. What is it? So there are so many favorite The Office romance lists online, like actual list of romances that fans really connect to. But there are 10 romantic scenes that everyone keeps coming back to,
to the internet, these are scenes that fans watch over and over. Are you ready? Yes. Number one, Jim's video to Pam. Oh. Yeah. The compilation of their love. Yes.
That was an AARM. Then I thought this was great. This was number two. When Bob pays $1,000 to hug Phyllis. Hmm. That was so sweet. In crime aid. In crime aid, he got into like a whole like bidding war with Twight.
number three when Dwight proposes to Angela okay am I crazy so that's also an AARM Jim's video to Pam and then Dwight's proposal at Angela what does it say about me that the way to my heart is Dwight's proposal more than the video the sentimental video I love just like the giant romantic gesture with all the like clunky like yes it was very emotional too. Yes. So raw. So raw. Well, you'll hear later. I pulled a clip of my favorite like meet cute and a romantic comedy and it has some elements of Dwight Angela, I think. Well, I have two clips to play as well at the end of this list and one of them is Dwight's proposal. I love it. I can't wait to hear it. So we had same brain there. And also the video is really touching. But as I have learned, this is an audio podcast. So I did not pick the video as a clip. Number four, Andy's 12 Days of Christmas for Erin. Oh, with the drum line at the end.
With the drum line. Yes. Number five, Jim's Wedding Toast to Pam. My gosh, is it bad? I don't remember it. What does he say? Oh, it's so great, lady. It is so great. In fact, that is one of my clips.
Oh, so, okay, thank you. This is working out pretty good. I'm playing two of the ones you're most curious about. Okay, number six, when Jim dresses as Popeye, and he dresses Cece as Sweet P for Pam. I love that. That's pretty sweet. Number seven, when Michael proposes to Holly, I mean, so great. Number eight, Dwight and Angela's actual wedding.
And in this article, it says many scenes from this one are fan favorites, but in particular, Dwight and Angela's first dance. When he, like, picks her up. Yes. Which was an improv, right? Yes. I mean, sort of. Her legs aren't working because they're very tired from being in the trunk. Yes. Basically, our first dance was going to be kind of clunky because Angela can't really, like, use her feet. And so Dwight was going to have to kind of maneuver her. But him picking me up and doing the tango and swinging me around, that was rain.
He improvised that and I just went with it. And I sort of stuck my legs out so they would fly around. Yes. Number nine, when Michael quits his job for Holly. They think that's a very romantic moment. And number 10, when Jim proposes to Pam in the rainstorm at the gas station. Yeah, that's a nice one. Yeah. But I thought, since it is our podcast, I would pick a Jim and Pam moment and a Dwight and Angela moment.
So let's hear that toast that Jim makes to Pam at their rehearsal dinner. All right. Hey, everyone. Thanks for coming. Yes. Oh, thanks, Pete. That was really nice. I just want to say how happy we are that all of you are here tonight, and I want to especially thank those of you who have traveled from far away to be here with us tonight, especially the Florida cousins, who obviously can't take a hint. Four years ago, I was just a guy who had a crush on a girl who had a boyfriend,
and I had to do the hardest thing that I've ever had to do, which was just to wait. Don't get me wrong. I flirted with her. Pam, I can now admit in front of friends and family that I do know how to make a photocopy. Didn't need your help that many times. And do you remember how long it took you to teach me how to drive stick? Like a year. I've been driving stick since high school. So, yes, yes. For a really long time, that's all I had. I just had little moments with a girl who saw me as a friend. And a lot of people told me I was crazy to wait this long for a day. date with a girl who I worked with, but I think even then I knew that I was waiting for my wife. So I would like to propose a toast. So if you'd all raise your glasses, not Pam, for obvious
reasons, but everyone else, if you would raise your glasses. Oh, for obvious reasons. And then, of course, this lovely toast goes off the rails because Nana's like, why? Why? And then Jim starts like, just completely flubbing. And then Michael, of all people, decides he's going to save it. And it's just a train wreck. But that toast is so lovely. It's really sweet. Really, really sweet.
And now let's hear Dwight's proposal to Angela. It starts with him running her off the road. Pull over. Why? Move to the side of the road. Why? Hold over! What is Dwight?
Dwight? What the f*** is your problem? Who drives like that? I love you. And I don't care the penelps not my son. I will raise a hundred children with a hundred of your lovers if it means I can be with you. Can you put that down?
This expresses how loudly I love you. It's too loud. This is a ring. Taken from the buttocks of my grandmother. Put there by the gangster patriarch of the Kors dynasty. Melted in a foundry run by Mennonites. Okay. Yes. Yes, I will.
You. I love you. I love you. And I lie to you. I lied to you. What? Phillips, your son. What?
Why would you say that? I just needed you to want to marry me because you wanted to marry me. Get out! I'm a dad! You're a dad! I mean, what great writing. Such good writing. That's probably why I like that proposal so much because I just, I love the poetic writing of that.
Yeah. I mean, I love the sentimentality of what Jim says. It's so from the heart. It's so beautiful. But, man, that is a good scene. Yeah. Both of those are so good. And we were just so lucky, man, to get to say those words and act out those scenes. It's, they are. They hold up. I get why they made the list. Well, you know, the office was also quite famous for dysfunctional relationships. Mm-hmm. There were a few. There were many. Who do you think had the most dysfunctional relationship on the office? Oh. Like who springs to mind? I mean, once again, I don't know, but like Angela and the senator and then Andy and Oscar, it's like, she had some crazy dysfunctional stuff, but then so did Michael.
I don't know. Are they a tie again? I don't know. This is just a discussion. I mean, there's Michael and Jan. Oh, so dysfunctional. Kelly and Ryan. Very dysfunctional. I did put Angela Andy on my personal list. Yes. I would put Angela and Andy and Angela and the senator. Yeah. What about Stanley, Cynthia, and Terry? Oh, man. Yeah. Stanley. I also put down Jan and Clark. Yes. I'm not sure what really happened there. Yes. Yeah. I mean, you know, and Michael and Pam's mom. I don't see. That's the thing. Like, I think.
think it was not great because it was Pam's mom, but they seemed to have a sweet relationship, although when it was over, Michael could barely ever remember that it happened. Also, he just turned on her so fast. He's like really stone cold dumped her. I know. I have a real life office romance I can share from history. From history. From history. I love a story from history. Yes. So you know Marie Curie. famous scientist, first woman to win a Nobel Prize. Yes. Also, the first person and only woman to win two Nobel Prizes in her lifetime.
But she had a real-life office romance with her husband, Pierre, who was also a scientist. They met doing science, like in the laboratory. I love when you use the term doing something. We do Game of Thrones. So we're doing science. We're doing our podcast. Yes. We're doing it.
Yeah, so she won her first Nobel Prize with her husband. And also, I don't know if I'm going to pronounce this name correctly, Henri Beccarell. They discovered radium. I mean, this is kind of cool. But did you know this? This is romantic. She was not originally included in the award. Pierre, her husband, had to write a letter to make sure she got credit for her portion.
of the research and that she was named on the Nobel Prize. He stood up for her. Way to go, Pierre. I know. They worked side by side all the time. And very often she was left out of recognitions. And there were a couple times when Pierre refused to accept a recognition because they wouldn't include his wife's name on it. And he was like, no, I won't come get your award. That's a good man right there. I know. Unfortunately, Pierre slipped and fell under the wheels of a horse carriage, and he died at the age of 46. Oh, no. I know. She was widowed very early. After his death, she won her second Nobel Prize in Chemistry. And then she died very young at the age of 66. They believe as a result of all of the radiation poisoning from all her research. Did you know that
her tomb, like where you can view her body is, I think, how do I word this? Her tomb is wrapped in one-inch led because her remains are still so radioactive that, like, people that view her body. Yes, I read that. Yeah. And also, her papers are considered, like, too dangerous to handle. Yeah. And so you have to, like, wear protective clothing. Yes.
But here are some quotes that they said about each other. Okay. Marie said, My husband and I were so closely united by our affection and our common work that we passed nearly all of our time together. He was a generous, gentle soul whose love and support made all my work possible. And then in a letter that Pierre wrote to Marie, he said, It would be a fine thing if we could spend our lives near each other, hypnotized by our dreams.
Oh my gosh, that's so lovely. I know, I know. You know, maybe it's just because Lee and I are both artists and we so often work together. I love when a couple shares a passion like that. And then they make it so that the other person can live out their dreams. It's so beautiful. It is. I'm going to share that with Josh, although he's probably listening right now because he listens to our episode every week.
Hi, Josh. Hi, Josh, babe. That's like me and you in the kitchen. It is. Oh, Jen, I love that. Well, you know, we also asked you all to send in your office romance stories and you really showed up for us. You sent in so many great moments. Let's start with Renee Kay in Jupiter, Florida, who wrote in and said,
My now husband and I used to work at the same company, and we met at an after-work happy hour. After we were introduced, he walked away to mingle with other people, but I kept noticing him watching me. It was like how Ryan noticed Jim staring at him when he was at reception. Then at work meetings, we used to catch each other's eye across the room. My husband would pretend to be shocked to find me looking at him, and then he would hide behind his papers. Now we've been together for seven years. Sometimes you find true love in a mundane workplace. Don't worry, kids.
You'll find the Dwight to your Angela. Aw. Isn't that cute? That is so sweet. I know. Okay, I grabbed one, and this is from Rachel M. in Los Angeles. Okay. Rachel said, in 2008, I started my first job in an office and my boyfriend of four years
that wouldn't take our relationship to the next step also worked there but in the warehouse. What? So Rachel worked in the office and her boyfriend of four years worked in the warehouse. Listen to this. A few months in, I met a guy at the office and immediately fell for him but couldn't say anything since I was dating someone. We were friends and went to lunch and talked every day, but I didn't have the guts to jump ship since it was so uncertain when I had something comfortable, and I had no idea if the new guy liked me. Rachel said, The Office seasons 1 through 3 were super influential to me because I resonated so much with Pam.
I mean, yes, Rachel, I can see why. You're living parallel lives. Truly. Rachel said, when Pam leaves Roy for Jim, another guy at the time. the office, and it turns out amazing. It gave me the courage to jump and choose the uncertain instead of staying comfortable and unhappy. I chose the other guy, and now we've been together 17 years, married and have a son. Thanks for giving me the courage to get what I want and never settle. The final monologue of Pam at the series finale makes me cry every time I see it since I
felt like it was exactly for someone like me who conquered my fears and got what I wanted since life just isn't that long. That is so wonderful. And again, look at that monologue that Pam had, that writing. I am just amazed as we're reviewing all of these scenes, just how our writers continue to touch people's lives by their amazing work. Well, that's good art, right? Yeah. That's good theater. That's good TV, good movies. You hear something spoken or reflected back to you and it transforms you. Yeah. And that's such good writing. Yeah. Absolutely. All right. We have another letter to share with you. This was an office-inspired romance as well. It's from Anna C, from Brazil, but now living in Belgium. She just wanted us to know that. I always love when
people give us those caveats. I love it. I want to know. I want to know. Anna said, the office didn't just make me laugh. It led me to the love of my life. In 2012, I threw myself a the office-themed birthday party. I even made a stapler in Jello like Jim's prank on Dwight. And one day I posted a photo on Reddit. And that's how I met my husband. He's from Belgium and we connected through the posts. Now we're married for two years.
And now I live in Belgium in a little rural town. And I'm learning Dutch. Your podcast keeps me company eight hours a day while I work. It's my daily joy. After we got married, we even flew back to Brazil just to bring my dog Frida to Belgium. Now she lives here with us with our Mel Bingle Cat Nova. We live in the countryside in a house surrounded by our little farm where we grow potatoes, onions, carrots, lettuce, broccoli, cauliflower, strawberries, raspberries, cherries, apples, pears, grapes, eggplants, peppers, peppers,
and, and of course, beats Anna. This is such, like, the most charming life. And they met because she threw herself an office-themed party and posted about it. I want to, like, put a big circle around that because like she took the initiative to celebrate herself yes and have this like very elaborate themed party i absolutely just love that about her and then it led to love yeah she put her true self out there yeah and she found someone who loved it and responded and now they have this life i just think that's wonderful they're animals and they're growing all their food and oh i loved it well listen why don't we go to break And when we come back, we're going to read more of your letters, and we are going to discuss some meat cutts, which is an essential part of a romance.
It really is one of my favorite parts to break down, as we know. Yes. And you even shared about it on our podcast, the origin of it. We'll revisit that. And guess what? What? We have our very own Kelly Kapoor's Meet Cute. We'll be back.
All right, we are back. Let's get into some meat cutts. Jenna, you researched the origin of the meat cute in the episode training day. Yeah, and you did a really good job. It goes all the way back to like 1938 to ye oldie movie, Bluebeard's eighth life. Anyway, there's a great meat cute there. It's over some pajamas. Jenna talks about it. But I loved it. Well, you know, the term meat cute is actually spoke. on the office. Yes, by Kelly in Training Day, which is what led me on my deep dive. Which was what led you on your deep dive. I know we've talked about it before, but I just love this scene. To me, this is Mindy, just having fun. Truly, this is not even work. She's just having fun. So the scene
is it's DeAngelo Vickers' first day. Kelly has put on a super cute, very stylish, like work business suit. It's got like a blue jacket with like a blue skirt. She's got these black like rimmed glasses. She doesn't wear glasses. It's just a prop. It's a total prop. And her plan is to catch DeAngelo's eye by dropping all these files and folders on the ground. And he's going to help her scoop them up. And his reaction is really funny. Let's hear it. I'll get that. You guys. Don't let's just, you know. It's just, you know. Hi. Hello.
Hi. Have we met before? No, not officially. I saw you coming out of the bathroom earlier. Well, I guess I'm going to go back to my cave. Okay. It's really great meeting you. And that is what they call a meet cute.
It's so funny. It's so funny to me, too, how DeAngelo is so clueless. Like, is this what happens, you guys? Like, do we think up these moments and then the other person? is just oblivious? Like, are meat cutes? Like, do they really happen in real time for each other? Or is it one person realizing and then the other person realizes it another time? Like, do they actually happen at the same time? I think it depends. I do. Yeah. I think there's some couples where one person like gets hit with Cupid's arrow first. Yeah. And then other times it happens at the same
time. Yeah. Because DeAngelo's answer is so honest. He's like, well, I saw you come out of the bathroom. But also, if it doesn't become a romance, is it a meat cute? That's true, you know? No, it's not a meat cute if the romance doesn't follow. I also don't think it's a meat cute if you manufacture it. Yeah, I'm not sure it counts, but I'll let other people debate that. Yeah. You know, and we never see the Jim Pam or the Dwight Angela meet cute. We actually got a letter about it. Jose V from Nutley, New Jersey said, In previous episodes, Jenna has explained how she created lore for Pam explaining how she got together with Roy and why it was so difficult from Pam's perspective to leave him. My question is for Angela.
Did she ever come up with Laura explaining how Dwight courted her? We all know they're together by the time Jim has his barbecue, but how did Dwight first approach Angela and what was that like? Oh, that's such a fun question. Well, you know, I sort of always thought somehow them both wanting to be the safety officer was what brought them together. That was the backstory I gave myself. You know, you have that moment where she goes to grab the first aid kit. And Dwight wants to take over and she's like, I'm the safety officer, not you.
Remember that whole scene? Yes, of course. And that's the first time they really speak to one another in the whole series. oh my gosh did they like get in a private argument that just then led to like a big makeout session was it just like a passionate like we never saw it on camera but like they got you know they got after each other about who was the safety officer and then it just ended up with it just a roll in the hay how did that's like where my mind is gone that is so funny that is your dwight natural meet cute it all starts with a fight i sort of saw them as having to take some class together that you know
know, I always thought this is really nerdy, okay, but this is what I thought. I could sort of see Michael being like, hey, we need a safety officer. Toby says we need a safety officer. I need someone to volunteer. And Dwight and Angela are the only two people that like sign up. Okay. And then they have to go through this, you know, sort of like the whole, you know, training little workshop together. And neither of them want to relinquish the role. So maybe there is this like like very sort of competitiveness. But yeah, that's where I saw them their first spark starting somewhere in this safety officer journey. I love it so much. I love thinking about them in safety officer train, just the two of them. Yes. And then at the end of the training, the teacher is like,
I pick Angela. Dwight's furious. But yeah, I don't know. I think that's kind of like where it all began for them. And it's how perfect is it that it's safety officer like school? Well, you know, in addition to sort of those meet cute moments, there are so many on the office that we actually get to see. Yeah. Yeah, I love Erin and Pete. Oh, yeah. I really like them. I mean, I know they don't end up together, but I like their arc. And, you know, sometimes a romance isn't supposed to be forever, but like you grow from it and it feeds your life. And so it's still, positive. That's how I feel about Aaron and Pete's romance. I feel like it started really in that Roy's wedding episode because back at the office, that's the episode where like Clark is being the
creeper and he's trying to hit on Aaron and get her that job in the news. Faky job. Like it's never going to happen for her to audition to be like a news anchor or something. Yes. And Pete like clocks it and then he becomes very protective. He even like makes it so that he's at the apartment. And then they get the hamburger afterwards. It's so sweet. Yeah. It's so sweet because he's just wanting to take care of her. And Andy's like, you know, she's hungry.
And Andy's like, take her to get a burger. And then there's that spy shot of them. Yeah. And they're clearly having the best time. I know. And after Aaron's just like trail of horrible romances, it just made me so happy. Yeah. I really want them to make it.
Well, we've been told they do not. I know, but I'm sorry. I know. Well, I don't think we can do a Meet Cute episode and not play Michael and Holly's Meet Cute. It's so good. So good. It's in Goodbye Toby. It's just the best. Okay, so I pulled two clips. The first one is the very first time they meet. And the second one is pretty much right after that because Michael is smitten pretty quickly. And Jim is like, dude, play it cool. Play it cool. I love Michael. in that scene with him so much. He's like, I love her. I love her. And then, anyway, he goes back in the annex looking for her and they have this conversation while she's trying to fix her desk chair. Yeah. Hey, Michael. Oh, hey, do you still work here? I'd like to introduce you to my replacement. Nah. Come on. No, I think I will pass. Michael Scott. This is Holly. Hi. Hi. Hi. Yeah, right. Okay. Well, they hired a female Toby. Good for the world. Thank you, God, for creating two of you.
Here's how things work here. My job is to make the office fun. Your job is to make the office lame. And we have an eternal struggle, you and I. And only one of us can be the winner. Spoiler alert. I'm going to win. Man, someone doesn't like HR.
Yeah. What did you do, do you do, him? Nothing. No, he tortured me with his awfulness. Yeah, I know what you mean. I nearly fell asleep when he gave me a tour of the files. Well, look, I'll let you get back to work, but I really look forward to working with you, Mr. Scott.
Michael. He can't even get his name out. He's so flabbergasted because the fact that she's, like, agreeing with him that Toby is boring, he's like, you are my soul mate. Yes. And now is when Jim's like, play it cool. And he goes back to the Anna. Let's hear that part.
That's how we buy them, actually. I'm trying to adjust the lumbar support on Toby's chair, and that made this up-down lever thing not work, and then I took the whole chair apart, and that is the story of me on the floor. It's pretty good, right? I'm going to sell the movie rights. And the sequel, Woman Stans at Descan works.
So, I have no idea how you... How you sit like that? Yoga. Sit on floor and put together a chair we will. Yo, duh. Um. Pass curvy metal piece, you will. So are you in town this weekend?
Because I'm not, I'm not, I'm not going to be in town. Going out of town. Oh, so you can't make my orgy? Kidding. Kidding. Acting! Acting! Acting!
Love it. Yeah. Oh my God. I don't know why. It, like, actually gives me chills listening to them. They could not be more perfect for each other. The look on Michael's face when she returns his Yoda impression, I mean, he can't, he literally does like a gasp. He's like, and then that she makes an orgy joke. He's crawling out of his skin. He can't believe this is happening. They're so perfect for each other. All right. Well, I asked everyone in
the office ladies group to pull a clip from their favorite meat cute in a movie. Because guys, I love meet cutes and I wanted to hear them. So where should we start? This was so fun, actually, because it gave us, I don't know about you guys, but to me, I got to revisit so many favorite moments of mine in movies. Yeah. I mean, it just puts you in a good mood. It does.
Sam, do you want to go first? Sure. mine is from my all-time favorite movie The Princess Bride I love that movie Our favorite pastimes were riding her horse And tormenting the farm boy that worked there His name was Wesley
But she never called him that Isn't that a wonderful beginning Yeah, it's really good Nothing gave buttercup As much pleasure as ordering Wesley around Farm boy Polish, polish my horse to saddle I want to see my face shining in it by morning
As you wish As you wish was all he ever said I just think it's just so sweet It just gets me to tears every time I know And then eventually we find out that as you wish means I love you As you wish
The part where she goes rolling down after him kills me to it. Yeah. Yeah. All right, Cassie. Mine is from the holiday. It's when Kate Winslet and Jack Black meet. I just love the premise of that movie of like switching houses and then they both fall in love. It's such a cool movie and that relationship in particular is just so cool and fun. And John Krasinski's in that movie. But he is? Yeah, he's Cameron Diaz's assistant. He's like an assistant like editor. Editor when it's like he's only in like you know, at the beginning. But yeah, that's kind of a little office crossover. But I love that movie, too. Do you have your clip? Yeah.
Hi. I'm so sorry. I'm new at the gate thing. It's okay. It was pretty funny. I'm Miles. I work with Ethan. Ethan? Amanda's ex. Oh, right. Right. Do you know when she'll be back? I'm supposed to pick up a couple things. Amanda's in England, actually, on holiday. I'm staying here for a few weeks where She's away. Oh. Uh-oh. You okay?
Yes. Somebody just blew into my eye. Oh, I hate that. Let me see. Yep. You got something in your eyelash. You want me to get it? Um, okay.
Okay. Yeah, Santa Ana's. Pardon? The wind. It's what makes it so warm this time you. Legend has it. When the Santa Ana's blow, all bets are off. Anything can happen.
That's it. You okay? better it's pretty stupid i have never heard of this santa anna wins like legend has it but i know but it's also like such a perfect l-a cute that like the santa anas are part of what brings them together and he like blows in her eye right or something like that holds like an eyelash out of her eye very gently yeah that's so cute i love it all right jenna should i go next yeah what's yours Angela? Well, you know, there's so many, so many moments. I love a meet cute. I love a rom-com. It was really hard for me to choose. But one that always cracks me up. And I think the chemistry in the
scene is so great. It's from crazy, stupid love. And it's when, you know, Ryan Gosling's character is this real slick guy. And he's going to hit on Emma Stone. And she's just like, who are you? What is happening? And they have this very funny exchange. And her, her, like, best friend is like at the table the whole time. So I sort of love that component too. Let's hear it. So much potential and you've resorted to fantasizing about Conan Ginger Junk O'Brien. He is funny. It looks like a carrot, honey. It looks like a carrot. Hi. It looks like a carrot. Conan O'Brien. My friend Hannah here thinks he's sexy. That's weird because I think that Your friend Hannah is really sexy.
Oh, my God. You did not just say that. How old are you? What are you, lawyer? I love it. Come on. I know. You on?
Is she? Got to me. Don't you think you're a little old to be using cheesy pickup lines? Objection. Leading the witness. Wow, Hannah, you're really wearing that dress like you're doing it a favor?
Oh, God. That's a line. Me sitting over there for the past two hours not being able to take my eyes off of you is a fact. I mean, there's lots of beautiful women in this bar. Your friend included. I love you, but I can't take my eyes off of you. That's a fact, it's not a line.
I find you very attractive. Do you find me attractive? She does. I don't. You do? She does. Yes, she does. I don't. You do.
I don't. Hannah, can I buy a drink? No. You say no a lot, don't you? No. Oh boy. Permission to approach the bench? Seriously?
Just come on, let me deliver my closing argument. Yeah, proceed. proceed. Anna, we live in a physical world, right? Uh-huh. And you're going to age, right? Mm-hmm. I guarantee you this.
You're never going to regret going home with a guy from the bar that one time that was a total tomcat in the sack. But I can't guarantee that you won't not regret it. It's a double negative. You're a double negative. Okay. Anna, you're going to buy a drink? Okay. You know what?
It's time to go home. Really? Mm-hmm. Wow. I'll do it. The T-boat saw free. So should I get my car, or yours? Can I pull the car around?
Have you been drinking? I'll try. Liz. Coming. Oh, my gosh. Isn't that so good? Okay, let me ask you this question. Sam Cassie, Angela, to all of us, would that work on you?
Are you heading home with Ryan Gosling? Hell yeah. I'm going home with Ryan Gosling. He walks out to my table like that. I mean, his speech, like, Like, listen, are you ever going to regret this one night? I would be like, no, I'm not. I'm not going to regret it.
I think I would go home with him, and I think it would take me a couple days to realize what happened. I would have to replay it in my brain to realize how I would get home with him. No, he wouldn't get two lines. Like, I would have shut him down right away to be like, get out of here. Cassie, I'm with you. I'm with you. I'm a no. I'm like, sorry, dude.
And I only think it works with Emma Stone's character because she's. at a weak point. And that's like, I think what's fun about that movie is they do end up falling in love. But I think she wouldn't have been a Jenna and me and shut them down immediately. But she did. She left. She does not leave the bar with them. No. She is later. And she's like, actually, now I want to do something impulsive. Yeah. You know, it's so funny. I have a friend of mine who's like a famous person. And she's sort of like, what do you call it? Like, you know, whatever. We're just like, just a scooch famous, just a scooch, right? Wait, this friend is a scooch famous. A scooch famous. Okay. And she was working on a project and
there was someone that was like a lead person who's super famous and super hot. And he kind of hit on her and she was like, hell yeah, let's go. And she tells her story of their night together is like, I hung on every word. She had a group of us, like, riveted and, you know, we're all sworn to secrecy, but she was like, I will never regret it for the rest of my life. She was like, it was so fantastic. It exceeded all of my expectations. He was good at all the things. And it was really funny after she told this story, one of our friends who, you know, when you've known someone so long, can just say the really honest thing. She was like, it's all downhill from here for you.
Like, never, nothing will ever be as good as that again. Anyway. But yeah, I still, and now when I see this person in movies, I can't help but think about it. Yeah, you're like, he does all the things really well. And then the other thing is she actually slept there. One of the things she said was that she wasn't planning on that so she didn't have pajamas or anything to sleep in. And he just had this box. He had just gotten a delivery. He was doing a branded campaign with some t-shirt company. And so he was like, oh, wait. And he went and he opened this
box. And he was like, here. And she was like, also, she was just so impressed at how much merch he had. So I was like, not only was this hookup amazing, but she got this really comfortable t-shirt. But she was like, it was so soft. And I walked, I went home with it. Anyway, it was so funny. I did not mean to share all that. But there you go. All right.
Well, I will share my favorite meat, cute scene. It's from the movie Moonstruck, which is my favorite romantic comedy. It goes between that and when Harry met Sally. But the Meek Cute and Moonstruck is just, oh, it's so good. So, you know, Cher's character is engaged to be married. She gets engaged to a very safe, stable man. She's been married before, and her first husband got hit by a bus. So she thinks she has bad luck in love. And so she's going to now marry this really safe choice. But he has bad blood with his brother, and he's going to fly out of town. And he says, while I'm gone, will you please go down and convince him. my brother to come to our wedding because that would make me so happy. So she goes down to meet Nicholas Cage, the guy's brother. He's a baker. And he's just, I mean, he's in his like, he's sweaty in a tank top. And he's shoveling bread into a hot oven. And he's super grumpy.
And she's like, hey, I'm going to get married to your brother, John. And he's like, I have no life. My brother Johnny took my life. And she's like, can we go somewhere to talk? And then he holds up his gloved hand and he reveals that one of his hands is actually a wooden prosthetic hand. And then he says this. Do you know about me? Mm-mm.
Okay. Nothing is anybody's fault. but things happen look this word is fake five years ago I was engaged to be married and and Johnny came in here and he ordered bread for me and I said oh okay some bread and I put my hand in the slicer and it got caught because I wasn't paying attention the slicer chewed off my hand This is funny because when my fiance found out about it, but she found out that I had been named,
she left me for another man. Is that the bad blood between you and Johnny? Yes, that's it. Yeah, but that's not Johnny's fault. I don't care. I ain't no freaking monument to justice. I lost my hand. I lost my bride.
Johnny has his hand. Johnny has his bride. You want me to take my heartbreak, put it away and forget. Put it away and forget. Yeah. Is that what she wants? Johnny has his hand. Johnny has his bride.
Yeah. Okay. So she's going to be like, okay, settle down. I'm going to take you up to your apartment. I'm going to cook you a raw steak. It's not how you like it. It's how you're going to eat it. Right.
Because you're the wolf. Yeah, he's the wolf. He's the wolf. And he needs the raw steak. He needs the steak. She's like, I think you're a wolf. I think you're a wolf. you chewed off your own hand because you were in a trap with the wrong woman, and that's how
you got yourself out of that relationship. And his mind is blown. He's like, doesn't know what to do with her. They end up just having a passionate love affair, but then she is like, I have to marry your brother, Johnny. I'm not going to marry you, okay? I had bad luck. I can't marry for love again. I did that the first time. And so I have to play this clip. This is. is when she has agreed to go to the opera with him to see him one last time, and then on the walk home, he leads her to his apartment again. And this is the speech he gives her about love. I love you. Not like they told you love is. And I didn't know this either. But love don't make things nice. It ruins everything. It breaks your heart. It makes things of
mess. We, we aren't here to make things perfect. The snowflakes are perfect. The stars are perfect. Not us. Not us. We are here to ruin ourselves and, and to break our hearts and love the wrong people and, and die. I mean that the storybooks are bullshit. I want you to come upstairs with me and get in my bed. Okay, so now I have to bring it to the group again. Are you going upstairs with him and getting in his bed after that speech on the snowy New York sidewalk? Yes. Yes, yes, a thousand times yes. Cassie.
I don't like to be yelled at. No, Cassie! Even if it's like passionate love yelling, you're like, tone the volume down, buddy. Bring it down. But if someone fetches an eyelash off your eye from the Santa Ana wins, Cassie is a puddle of goo. This is what we've learned. I have to say, though, I also, Jenna, from that movie, I love the line when her mom, Mom, who's played by, is it Olympia Dukakis, who's so amazing?
So good. So good. She says to her daughter, Cher, she goes, do you love them, Loretta? And Loretta goes, Ma, I love them awful. And then her mom goes, oh, God, that's too bad. I know. It's such a great line. Oh, that was really fun.
I loved that prompt, Jenna. Well, thanks, guys. I love a romance. I really do. I think we learned a lot about each other. today. And a lot about a very handsome, unnamed celebrity. Oh, yeah. Well, I'm sworn to secrecy for my life, but she got the t-shirt. Well, we got a letter that could honestly be the plot of a movie. It's so sweet. It's from Kaylee Kay in Chippewa Falls, Wisconsin, and here it is.
Kaylee says, I thought I'd share my meat cute, or what I like to call it, my first kiss and my last kiss story. My husband and I actually met in kindergarten. He was my best friend. I like to think it's because he loved tractors and I loved them as well. We even shared the same bus route and I got the courage to kiss him. He was so mad at me because he was absolutely embarrassed since everyone saw it on our school bus. The next year he switched to a different school, but we still saw each other throughout the years because we were in 4-H, went to camp together, and eventually worked at the same restaurant. At that time, my husband told me he liked me, but I didn't feel the same about him. We still spent time with each other through the next few years because of mutual friendships.
Eventually, after a couple of failed relationships and really reconnecting, he asked me out, and the rest is history. We were engaged 10 months later and married a year later. We've been married for five and a half years, starting to buy the family farm and starting to build a house in just a month. I'm putting a plug in for my husband also. I'm so incredibly lucky to have him and he is truly the best man. It's funny how things work out and I really believe everything has a timeline. He was my first kiss and he'll be my last. Aw, how sweet is that? Super sweet. So, so sweet. I think it really shows how timing is everything too. It's so true. I mean, we've talked about this many times. The right person can come along. But if the
timing isn't lining up, it doesn't happen then. I know. But look at how the universe like kept putting these two in each other's world. That's from kindergarten all the way to adulthood. The universe was like, we know who you're going to be with. We're just waiting for you to figure it out. For you guys. Yeah. Yeah. You know, we did get quite a few people who wrote in asking you and I to share our meetcutes with our husbands. And I thought it would be fun if we did. Okay. Who should go first? You go first. Okay, well, it's interesting because we're talking about how timing is everything.
I actually met Lee, gosh, maybe 10 or 11 years before we fell in love. So wild. I knew him a very, very long time. We had a mutual friend in common. Lee would sometimes come to like birthday parties or weddings. you know, like when you gather all this sort of like mutual friends of a friend group, Lee would sometimes be there. And I always thought he was a nice guy, but he was just not on my radar and I was not on
his. Then fast forward like 10 years from the time we met and I was looking to produce a movie, a romantic comedy. As we know, I love them. And I was taking meetings with different writers. and Lee was a writer and was sort of this like, what would you call it? Like peripheral friend. Right.
Yeah. And so I had a pitch meeting with him and I loved his idea the best. It was just incredible. And that pitch eventually became the movie The Giant Mechanical Man. And while I was producing that movie and we were putting it together and he was writing it and we were going back and forth like on notes, we were talking about what is romance what is love how do you fall in love oh my gosh i mean here's some dialogue of people falling in love jena why don't you read it and i would read it and i would be like wow wow and we fell in love that is how we fell in love it's sort of like an office romance in a way
as well yeah you know what's so wild to me is that i know this story you know but i sort of didn't really connect with until you just saying this out loud was the fact that you guys were basically creating a romance and sharing with each other what you think love is. Yes, as a project. And that is so crazy to me. I sort of did not put that together. That's so wild. Wow. But what's so funny is like after we fell in love, it was just so obvious that he was my person. that it kind of blew my mind that I had been around him for 10 years and I didn't know it. And we would even say things to each other. I would be like, now, wait, you must have been like such and such as wedding, right?
And he's like, yes, I was at that wedding. I'm like, I have no memory of you at that wedding. He's like, I have no memory of you at that wedding. Oh, my gosh. Like, we didn't speak. You have got to share that story with your kids someday. I think they would just get so tickled by it. Well, I will share it with them because it really is about how timing is everything.
Yeah. You know? Yeah. We just, we didn't see each other that way for many, many, many, many years until we were both ready. I love that because it's so true. I mean, for Josh and I, you know, it's so funny to me because I met Josh's oldest son before I met Josh. So our kids were at preschool together, and I was working on the office, so my call time was like 5.30 in the morning. So I could never drop Isabel off, but I would go and have lunch with her.
This was one of the great things is that I was often able to leave the set and go have lunch with her. And I would always arrive to her little preschool at story time. And they would sit in a circle under this big tree and have story time. It was the sweetest thing. And I remember the first time I met Jack. I don't remember the first time I met Josh. I guess I had met him a few times, but he's never on my radar. But we're sitting there for story time. And Isabel's sitting in my lap, like crisscross applesauce, you know. And the teacher, Amber, and this is part of our whole family lore now. The kids love this. The teacher Amber, who was just like, if you could manifest a hug into a human, she was just the most lovely person. She's reading her story. She's reading her story.
and she stops, and she looks at a little boy who is face down licking the dirt on the ground. Okay. And then she goes, hey, Jack, dirt is not food, okay? So we're not going to eat the dirt. And he kind of raises his face up, and he's got, like, dirt around his mouth. And I was like, oh, my gosh, like, I'll never forget this kid. This kid is so funny. Then, like, a year later, I go to volunteer.
They had a bunch of Legos and parents. volunteered to build, you will not believe this, different pieces of the Star Wars, like ships and stuff. Okay. Yeah. And you're like, I'll sign that. I was like, I'll sign up. Yeah, I'm horrible at Legos, but I'll go volunteer to build some Star Wars stuff.
And Josh was working on the Star Wars stuff and he's really good. I guess he'd been volunteering a few times, but it was the only time I went. I was horrible at Legos. He said he remembers that I was so bad that they had to go back and redo like some of my build. But anyway, and I remember being like, oh, that's a nice person. And then I started realizing connecting the dots, like, oh, that's Jack's dad. That's so nice. Then again, not on my radar.
I was, like, traveling. I went to Europe and I got back. This is like months and months later. And I'm at my grocery store, like my neighborhood grocery store, I always go. And I turn the corner with my cart. And I almost run into Josh. And I'd never seen him at my grocery store before. And he said, oh, you know, I just want you.
know, I moved and I'm in this neighborhood now. And, you know, we were both single parenting, so we talked a little bit about that. And I just mentioned to him that I was like, hey, you know, I'm having a birthday party if you'd like to come. And he was like, sure. Now Josh thought I was inviting him like to an adult birthday party. I didn't think to mention that I let Isabelle plan my birthday party that year because I didn't really care. It wasn't a big number. And Isabel loved the little mermaid and she loved mermaids so her and my friend micha micka you know he's like her sort of like l.A uncle you know he's one of my dear friends he helped isabel plan this party for me because she was like four years old you know yes it was full mermaid theme i also told isabel she could invite
all of her friends that it really it could be her party yeah so she invited all of her friends It was a swim party. I got a mermaid-themed birthday cake. And Josh arrives to my house, and he's dressed really cute. And he, because it was a swim party in the late afternoon, so the sun wouldn't be too hot. So it started at like 4 p.m. You know? Because I'm thinking I have these young kids.
I don't want him to get sunburn. Anyway, Josh arrives around 4.30-ish, and he walks in dressed really nice with a bottle of wine. Of course. He's coming to your birthday. Yes. And he walks out. And I had a few. It was all moms, you know, like moms and their kids mostly.
And like I had invited my ex-husband and his fiancé, you know. And they're like, what is Josh doing here with a bottle of wine? Like who is this guy with a bottle of wine? And he said that it was like a record scratch for him. He walked out and he was like, oh. she like wasn't like he thought maybe at the grocery store I was kind of maybe flirty like hey do you want to come to my but I was just like do you want to come you? You were just being Angela you were just yes you live nearby you should come to my house for party this is so you yes and he said he felt so awkward and he
could not wait to get out of there he only stayed for like 30 minutes and then he was like all right well I'm going to go where should I leave the wine and I'm like oh you know near the craft table I don't You know, it was such like a kid party. But that is the moment that I like sort of saw him, you know? That's what I was going to ask you. Yes. Like when he showed up thinking nice, this might be, you see him and be like, oh, oh, he's thinking, well, oh, okay, wait. Yes, it was exactly that. So it was like a long time, like much later that finally we went out to dinner. and went and saw a movie and that was like kind of like oh okay this is this is a date so sweet I know so sweet I love that kids your friendly nature Star Wars mermaids are all part of that story I know and you know I do like really empathize when people share their meat cutts like some of them
are like oh this was so long it's like how do you put that in a soundbook you know like yeah that's just life and how it unfolds and it's it's not always just immediate sometimes things that are really worth something play out over time yeah uh I just have a smile on my face I love talking about love I do too I love it so much I love it so much I just want to thank everyone who wrote in you know this was such a fun episode to do and thank you Jenna for prompting us to watch great rom-coms. Well, we hope you have a really good week. Please be sure to check out the How We Made Your Mother podcast now on Office Ladies Network and available wherever you get your podcasts. I mean, that's really a whole TV show about
a meet-cute romance. It is, and so fun, too. All right, we'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz.
Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.